eeuu no descarta una acción militar
contra irán como último recurso si la
república islámica pretende tener armas
nucleares y no llegar a un acuerdo
aunque el presidente joe biden prosigue
su visita por israel estas palabras al
canal 12 israelí han generado desde
anoche una gran repercusión en la
entrevista que fue grabada antes de su
salida de washington vaivén matizó que
si creyendo en el pacto nuclear de 2015
y de hecho tildó de error gigantesco que
su antecesor donald trump lo abandonará
en 2018 ahora bien dejó claro que
mantendrá la guardia revolucionaria
iraní en esta lista de grupos
terroristas extranjeros incluso si esto
perjudica las negociaciones con irán que
hoy siguen estancadas por otro lado el
mandatario estadounidense reiteró una
integración y seguridad para israel en
la región que hoy pasaría por acercar a
árabe saudita a israel si bien admitió
que esta posible normalización de
relaciones llevaría mucho tiempo apuntó
una mayor aceptación entre ambos
siguiendo esa línea de los acuerdos de
abraham en este sentido recalcó el
interés de eeuu en medio oriente para
evitar un vacío que pudieran ocupar
naciones como rusia y china a eeuu como
dijo le interesa un israel estable
integrado con los países árabes y con
ello consideró que sería más probable
que pudiera darse un eventual acuerdo de
paz con los palestinos por último sobre
sus compañeros demócratas que denuncian
las políticas y leyes de israel hacia el
pueblo palestino como un sistema de
apartheid by then sentenció que son
pocos y que están equivocados mientras
que dijo que no se disculparía sobre los
miles de millones de dólares que eeuu
dedica a israel principalmente en
defensa